I do I do apologize for more detail I
should have known by now but actually I
was in the wrong room that that's the
most stupid mistake I should have made
anyway I apologize for that
um anyway
um
I just want to introduce myself a little
bit I am very nice I'm very happy to be
here and I I call in the end I call this
slide a short summary of myself in logos
you'll really see a lot of loggers here
I have a background in computer science
my phds in machine learning for software
engineering which is kind of interesting
uh field I've been doing some research
for machine learning and biomedical
field
and now I did science
um that scientists advocates for
Anaconda as well as software
accessibility fellow Institute fellow uh
in the UK uh I'm also python Geck so you
can talk me python I'm organizing by
data Euro sci-fi Pike in Italy you might
be probably hearing something about it
later maybe lighting talk who knows
um I'm also casual majority Gathering
player I'm keep on saying this thank you
I actually brought my deck so if you
want
um I I keep on saying this and the first
time I said that I didn't have my deck
with me and there were players there so
yeah I do have it nice so I'm very very
glad
um that some of you are also playing
um
on my screen there's the next slide I
don't know why I didn't
there you go
I think there's one slide anyway uh that
was just to ask you for patience and the
show events I'm going to ask you a few
questions just to understand where we
had with this talk and I wanted to ask
you first how many new know what pi
script is
nice I'm not completely ruined my
presentation good I do have slides for
those of you not knowing what by Script
is actually good for me uh how many of
you have actually used
Pi script now
okay good right
I hope you will be using after this talk
maybe maybe
and uh how many of you already see me
blubbing about Pi script
good I can reuse all means nice
and how many of you has attended uh have
attended Antonio's talk yesterday from
yesterday on webassembly
fantastic so for those of you who were
there yesterday Antonio and my colleague
from Anaconda talked about were busably
the project blah blah I will be
essentially this is a good segue and
we'll be talking about typescript which
is one application on webassembly so for
those of you I hope that we sort of
close the circle from Antonio's talk
from yesterday which was was fantastic
indeed
nice so
what if we could run python in the
browser
and in particular what if we could
actually embed
python code within HTML
actually this is the the what you look
at when you see uh pisgroup.net which is
the website for pi script the project
and
um
indeed python in the browser is as
simple as you just have a new
um a new tag which is called Pi Dash
script and and within this tag you can
actually write some python code
and the only the the way in which you do
this is essentially importing some kind
of a weird Pi script.js on the top
I know this might look like strange to
you and the first time I I've seen this
was like okay what's going on is it like
really python is it like JavaScript
python what was that so I I decided to
and I know you might be thinking PHP
Vibes nice so we'll be back again in
having HTML code mixed with logic code
and something else so it's like a
mixture of different things I I won't
shout I promise
um and uh and so
I will be starting telling you what pi
script is by telling you what pi script
is not
and in particular I just want to make
crystal clear in the very beginning that
Pi script is not at all comparable to
any server-side technology like PHP or
any technology injecting server-side
code into HTML that is completely not
the point and in fact is it client-side
technology everything happens in the
browser doesn't necessarily require a
remote server to run and you can deploy
a pi script application as simple as you
can deploy an HTML file which means you
just put there and it works
um
and so
again when I started looking at this it
was like okay like HTML quivering a
little bit you know Tomcat Java Java
server pages and for those of you who
have the pleasure like myself to work
with these kind of things this is how
Java server Pages look like it's just
like some sort of a
strained Java code within HTML to do
some computation but though that this
specific technology requires
Tomcat server tangent so it's a
server-side technology again and the
main drawback of these technology is
where you're mixing essentially
everything all together so
representation logic programming Logic
No that's really bad so at that point
templating languages were developed so
if you're familiar with Django for
example you might know that Django has a
template language which is specific to
the framework and the Very point of that
template language is I don't want to
have any python real python running in
the browser because that would be
uh console business logic I just want to
have presentation logic and so this is
the the new feature of template language
require specifically designed for
presentation but Pi script is a
client-side technology so there's no
server bringing the the
um business logic or the data into the
router everything lives within the
browser and from what it's worth at this
point we might say that the mixture you
have with pi script with presentation
and logic programming is the same as you
have with JavaScript
same thing
speaking of which elephant in room
that's one of the meme I can reuse
um before Pi script we can summarize
that in case you were choosing between
javascript.python
you'll probably go for python in this
room I'm I'm I guess but now you can
actually choose both
and this is one of the main advantage of
of using pi script I will be showing you
a concrete example in a second I will be
actually looking at the time as well
so what are the main advantages of Pi
script is well first off Pi script is
not like JavaScript and for those of you
attending the talk yesterday you might
know this already but it's the point is
not replacing JavaScript there are two
completely different Technologies at all
so uh even in In from from a technical
and Architectural perspective
but there's a big but but um Pi script
can interact with JavaScript and so you
can enhance for interavailability
so for example in the snippet you
already might see something like that so
this is pi script and so everything is
within Pi script is python code so what
you're looking at is genuine python code
that makes available to inter
interoperate directly and I promise you
this works directly with the JavaScript
interpreter running in the browser so
you can do something like from JS import
to document control Json and then you do
document.gem get element by ID as you
would do in JavaScript code by using
python
okay
um so now we we're in this room Pi data
conference I think I want to put the
attention on what is the benefit of
using this technology for pilot projects
and actually this might probably why you
you might expecting from me now as in
where is the actionable machine learning
you've been blobbing about in the title
so Pi script is
um so this was one of the first picture
like sketched
by Peter and Fabio the creators of all
the projects and uh this is indeed um a
genuine representation of the
architecture of the project Pi script is
essentially built on top of piudide
which is one which is The Interpreter by
default piadite is the C python
interpreter compiled via M scripton to
web web assembly and so this is how the
stack works are the very end of the
stack you have wasm and which is the
actual computational engine that makes
everything working in the browser
and and just for you to know uh there's
a has been announced or I think late
March this year in in the pi script
ecosystem that we might be supporting
order
uh interpreters like micro python for
example which is another implementation
of a python interpreter over webassembly
so I can probably show you this I hope
so for example in this example here you
might find the link in the slides you
can switch between
so this code is I promise you is running
in the browser there's no server
um there apart from hosting the HTML by
the way but so I can switch between two
interpreters and everything works so now
I'm using piadite and you can tell
because of the of the spinning wheel
here and you might also realize that it
takes some time because of a reason I
will be telling you in a second and this
is the code executed in piodied and this
is micropython It's instant speed so
the
um advantages of having multiple
interpreters mean it means that you
might have multiple use cases multiple
requirements so piudide has lots of
advantages and I will tell you in a
second what are those but if you don't
need what pay your dad is actually
giving to you but you need Speed and
Performance you might want to switch to
a different interpreter like micro
python for example
and I will be happy to talk about it
actually
later this is just the wrong
presentation
let me go back to that there you go
sorry
good so let's have a quick look and at a
time as well
um
are about what's the difference between
pi script and polite I've been telling
you that Pi script sits on top on
piodite so at some point you might be
wondering okay but why do I want to use
Pi script instead of using pi directly
well piudide is fantastic and the first
thing that Pi Day brings to you is like
you have full python standard library
and I want to stress this out very
clearly you're actually written it
you're actually writing within Pi script
tags genuine python code I will be
having an example later on like bringing
a python code works on my computer
standard python rigging into the browser
and it works okay so if there's no
difference between the python you write
there and you on your computer and in
the browser it is indeed foolish python
library because everything is supported
in the standard library but a few
modules some some something like uh
ensure pip idle idle lib lib two to
three they're not supported but you
might hardly need and also they're
included but not really working
multi-processing threading and sockets
the reason for this is because they this
libraries actually work different on
webassembly so that's why they're not
supported yet
um
just for you know probably ID is a
spinoff project for the yodai project
which was kicked off by Mozilla now
discontinued and essentially the goal of
your died back in the days was bringing
scientific Computing in the browser so I
think we are exactly talking about the
the right thing and because of this
piudide because it senses python in the
browser for scientific Computing piadite
and this is probably one of the main
advantages brought by biodide and so uh
to by extent to Pi script is is
providing the full pilot attack already
in the browser so you don't need to
install numpy you don't need to install
anything most of the packages are
already there thanks to piudide bringing
those packages to web assembly this is
the main advantage
so I already already have Empire died
bokeh Network X numpy sci-fi second
learn you name it and and indeed there
is a web page telling you the exact
version a list of packages supported by
default in piudide and the list actually
goes on and on and you can spot some of
those very popular there you have sci-fi
cycle learn psychic image you have x-ray
plenty of libraries already there
and so this means that the browser now
becomes a ubiquitous virtual machine
and the reason for that is like you can
have you can enable scientific Computing
but just writing this code into an HTML
file bring this file to somebody who
doesn't neces doesn't require to have at
all python installed their computer
they just opened the browser and it
works
so because the The Interpreter is
actually downloaded automatically and
The piolide Interpreter so the python
interpreted on piudide and so whatever
you have installed in your computer
doesn't matter everything works within
the sandbox of the web assembly on in
the browser and this is one of the main
advantage and one of the main goal of
the pi screen project bringing
programming to the 99 you can program
python code in the browser with no
installation whatsoever you don't need
any uh
installed interpreter on your computer
anymore
and so just to make you appreciate a
little bit the difference between the
now piodide and Pi script so this is
genuine piudide if you want to write
piolite code and to install some
packages within your
page this is the code you should be
running something like asynchronous core
routines in Python Pi that load package
and essentially pilot includes a project
a sub module which is called a micropip
which is how pile ID installs packages
from from the web in part of that you
can install will packages as well as
soon as they are compiled specifically
for wasm as in this example or they're
pure python so no C dependency because
they work on wasn't otherwise they don't
um I'll go very quick now in pi script
on the other hand what you can do is
just having a tag specifying the config
of your application so you have Pi
config packages numpy bokeh cycle learn
and essentially they're calling for you
micropip on piodite
um
this is another example another good
bits of having Pi config with respect to
piodide in pi script you know can
actually load custom modules so for
example I can load custom data files and
have it have it working
um this is other options you have in pi
config I just want to now and Jason's
format is also supported not just Tamil
and now I want to introduce probably
another quite interesting contribution
of Pi script it's called pyreple so in
pi script
um we do have a tag which is called
pyreple and the pi reple is indeed
um
implementing what you're expecting a
read and evaluation uh
command line
um
you know why it's taking so long I
should have checked in the internet
connection I need the Internet for all
everything
um
let me check that
it's taking some time there you go I
think it was the internet at this time
so what I can do here I can do oh let me
Zoom a little bit I can import
anti-gravity that's actually quite a
nice example here do you know what what
and to gravity does this is what Andrew
gravity does normally no so if you do
this in your terminal this is what you
get but in pi script you can also do
anti-gravity Dot
fly
and the way you do this is you can
actually look at the code is genuine
python code there's a Rewritten version
of anti-gravity class but what you're
doing is essentially you're manipulating
through a few lines of python the SVG
generated by the the anti-gravity thing
um
let me go back to the example now
and before diving into a few demos I
have let me just tell you one important
things because at some point you might
be wondering okay how do I actually work
with pi script should I actually write
everything in the HTML file you can but
I would recommend well there is ID and
editor support you have python support
now actually the pilotide team has has
released this tab file that you can
actually use to integrate within your
editor so when you're writing in vs code
for example you have Auto completion for
the JS module for the pylon module
specifically for the GS module
and also I'm very glad to announce you
that we as Anaconda we launched a new
project is called postgroup.com which
you may think of it as of now as what J
yes fiddle is for JavaScript I've been
telling I'll be showing you exactly that
so that's demo time I have very few time
so I will be going our through many
things
um
the first example I thought to to talk
through is not really relating to
machine learning but it was like uh
there was taken from a previous
presentation of mine and essentially
what I'm I'm doing here is
is well I'm showing some some
connections using networks or
connections of our Star Wars characters
in different movies
um and the internet is not helping me at
all here
um there you go but what I'm actually
doing here I'm using V3 v3.js to
generate the graph so I'm indeed
integrating python code within our D3
and I can switch here generating the E3
and if you want to have a look at the
code and also have a look at how
buyscrew.com looks like
so we can click on view code and one of
the main advantage of of playscrew.com
is
and it's totally free you just need to
log in and that works you have
everything all together so you have code
and the preview here but the good bits
in this particular case is that since
you've been seeing someone else's
project like I'm doing or pretending I'm
not myself at this moment uh I can
actually copy this project I'm bringing
this into my account so that that's
pretty convenient feature and as soon as
I do this essentially I'm copying
everything into my environment now I can
add as many files as I want and
essentially all the code I was showing
you was like genuine python code at some
point integrating with d3.js
um
I'm taking time from questions now so I
I think I will be showing you a few of
the examples I've actually planned to
hear but
um let me just quick quickly I just want
to show you two things super quickly the
first thing is
this so let me show you this file here
I don't know what's going on okay so
this is a genuine python file and I can
show you it's like nothing particularly
fancy it's just like importing
um importing some data in the main like
from second learn and it's plotting the
class distribution and plot feature
metrics all right so if you don't trust
me as you should
I can just run this project in the
terminal
is it doing anything
demo timing
nice
all right let's try again
and it's not even JavaScript oh
anyway so let's try different things let
me just
um I'll I'll go on no no I'll take the
time I will want to show the demo that's
fine for the questions
that's fine
I think I have five minutes to do I have
five minutes left right
three nice I can do that
stay with me
[Music]
um
where is this
nice it doesn't exist anymore oh yeah
because it's not a folder
so what I'm trying to do here is running
this thingy
I'm probably not in the right
environment yes I'm plotting this stupid
and then I'm plotting another one stupid
as well but what I want to do now is
like taking everything here
and it's not fancy code it's just like
code
I create a new project
I plot it in
in the main
which is automatically created for me
there you go
and then I just
replace the main here into HTML
everything is ready
prepared for me
um what I will probably wanting to do is
something different
as in utility
let's say utils not buy
okay and then main is it big enough by
the way
okay A C clapping so I'm late I know as
usual
I just want to copy this here
there you go
then I want to import this and probably
I should also import some dependencies
because I need for this code I need
numpyte I need scikit-learn
I need
multiple clip
nice and also I want to fetch a local
module
which is called
utils
dot by
nice last bit
I want to now copy the main here
nice I just need to import the functions
I need from utils I call it utils this
time
and then uh blah blah I have to just
avoid using this Plot show but I will be
doing this
I will be so this is figure I display
the figure
into a Target
which doesn't exist yet
but it will
I know
figure yeah sorry I'm giving you the
hard time I know I apologize for that
um fig and Target
feature and last bit
Stay With Me
was the type of there
thank you you're very kind
um okay now we have the ID we have to
create which is class is it why do I
call it
classroom feature done bus l
yeah
I know you've been very pushy
just let me show you this and I'm done
I know I know just just bear with me I
promise
no I know I know you're right you're
very German
and I'm very Italian to be honest
please work
he takes actually a bit of time because
the competition runs in the browser and
I do thank you very much for patience
everybody
it should be working though it doesn't
foreign
yes